Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of Salah the chapters
regarding the timings of prayer.
forch.
[Silence]
The author says and this is actually one
of the very very lessernown
narrations, lesserk known sunnah
and that is that the author mentions a
pro another prohibited time to make sal
is after the adan of fud.
before the obligatory salah of
anything beyond
the to
the sunnah of
anything beyond that is not permissible.
What what do I mean? So the adan of
comes in the time for
what is the time for now? 5:15
let's say 5:15 to make it easy. So 5:15
and
is at 5:45 for us.
The only thing permissible for a person
to pray is two.
That should be the only thing that is
being prayed between 5:15 and 5:45.
The person then makes the salah of and
then is done making salah until the sun
rises
15 minutes after the sunrise. Right? A
lot of people, maybe even many, maybe
even most of the common people do not
know this.
Between the adan of and the of is only
two.
Wherever a person happens to be, if a
person is waiting for the in the masid,
then when they enter the masid, they
make only two.
that to they intend
by making it and it includes
and we discussed this before. A person
makes wudoo.
A person makes woodoo
and then they come to the masid. They
make only two and the intention of
is all in two and that is it. So a
person is not to pray before or after
except for the two
that is it.
He then mentions the narration of
what does it mean?
What is ma
mahar mahi
mah
freed slave? Very good. You have a
slave, you emancipate him. He remains
your mah, which means that his
allegiance is always to the person that
freed him. And this not only happens
with individuals but it also happens
with entire tribes or nations.
You look at the nations in which Islam
was spread into them during the time of
the companions and
every one of those cities and tribes has
a wa to someone because they are the
ones that called them into Islam. They
accepted Islam at their at their
you know the these people are the ones
that brought Islam to them. So their
allegiances to those people in a
figurative sense in a spiritual sense is
as if they freed them emancipated them
from the fire. And so ma here is that
this is the freed slave the emancipated
slave of Iban. And often times a ma
would remain a close companion and a
servant to the person that
emancipated them. Right? When a slave
is is owned by a person and
then they are working to become
emancipated. First of all, not all of
them want to be emancipated. But those
who do want to be e emancipated,
when they emancipate them, they don't
just, you know, tie their belongings to
the end of a stick, throw it over their
shoulder, and walk off into the sunset,
right? Their entire livelihood is right
there. All the people they've ever known
in their whole life, right? And so they
remain very close with the person that
emancipated them. And usually they
desire emancipation
for certain reasons either for business
reasons or because they want to get
married to someone particular something
that. It's not because they feel
their life is terrible because they
are a slave. That's not the case. A lot
of times being a slave is more rewarding
Islam in Islam is more rewarding and
easier than being free. And Abu Hurra
famously said, "Had it not been for the
anger of my mother against me, I would
have chosen to die as a as an owned
slave due to the great reward that the
slave receives for obedience to Allah
and then obedience to his master. He
receives twi twice the reward."
So Abu said, "Had it not been for the
disobedience of my mother, I would have
chosen to die as a slave." Right?
Omar, he says Omar once saw me while I
was praying after the time of was in and
he said to me, "Yeah, his name is Yas.
Indeed, the messenger of Allah
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam once
emerged and found us, emerged from his
home into the masjid, saw us, the
companions
praying this same prayer, meaning taking
the opportunity of waiting for salah to
continue to pray optional prayers in
sets of two between the adan of and the
of and the messenger of Allah then said
to us, "Let Those who hear me now inform
those who are absent. Let those present
inform those who are absent. Do not pray
after the time of fud except for two sas
meaning in two raas.
This narration is collected by Abu D and
collected by with a slightly different
wording but a very very clear
wording. He says
there is no prayer to be made after the
adan of except for
two being what
right?
That is the only thing that should be
prayed. And if a person is waiting at
home to pray fud the sunnah is to lie on
his side until the time of salah. And if
he is waiting at the masid to pray, the
sunnah is to make dua.
[Silence]
myself.